for the dough mix first slice the leek  lengthwise and chopped and sowed in a  pan with olive oil and butter till  tender season next combine flour for the  pinch of seasoning and olive oil and mix  in your cooked leeks bring the dough  together in a bowl with a drop of warm  water cover and rest for 20 minutes  allow the dough mixture to relax means  the resulting bread will be nice and  soft then dust the dough with flour mold  into a sausage shape slice it into  rounds  and flatten with a rolling pin  [Music]  then simply frying in a hot dry pan  [Music]  when golden and crisp on each side  remove for a simple supper  serve with a cottage cheese lemon zest  and fresh thyme so simple so fast and so  versatile flatbreads  to die for